et bien bonjour à toutes et à tous j'ai
choisi aujourd'hui de venir vous parler
de la passion qui m'anime depuis l'âge
de 6 ans la danse classique
[Musique]
alors quel rapport me direz-vous entre
l'université savoie mont blanc et la
danse classique
aucun en fait je vais vous parler
d'organisation être performance et je
souhaite partager avec vous aujourd'hui
ma vision de l'entreprise en
l'illustrant au travers d' analogie avec
la danse et vous présentez également
vous expliquer comment au quotidien dans
mon métier de consultant en organisation
je retrouve les valeurs et les
fondamentaux de la danse classique
alors je vais commencer par quelques
définitions l'organisation
l'organisation c'est quoi le larousse
nous dit l'organisation sous l'action de
structure et d'aménager d'agencés la
danse la danse c'est l'art de s'exprimer
au travers de compositions
chorégraphiques de suite de mouvements
de part la plupart du temps sur le son
d'une musique et la performance
la performance c'est un exploit c'est un
acte remarquable quel que soit le
domaine
la performance son entreprise on peut la
retrouver à différents niveaux des
machines peuvent être performante des
processus des hommes également peuvent
être performant c'est cet ensemble
machine hommes processus qui composent
l'organisation
l'entreprise a donc une structure
l'organisation et pour se développer
elle doit avoir aussi une stratégie la
structure c'est la base c'est la
fondation sur laquelle va venir
s'appuyer la stratégie la structure est
solide
la stratégie est un peu plus mouvantes
elle est clairement définie elle donne
le cap mais elle doit être resté à
l'ecoute du marché extérieur des
éléments extérieurs
elle doit s'adapter continuellement
quand l'organisation et la stratégie
sont en phase la performance est au
rendez vous dans la danse c'est la même
chose on va parler de technique et de
style la technique
le danseur l'acquiert au travers de la
danse classique et le style c'est le
reflet de la personnalité c'est là la
façon dont le danseur va se différencier
des autres danseurs
la technique c'est la base la fondation
sur quoi le style va venir s'appuyer on
a donc on voit donc la danse classique
est à la danse ce que l'organisation est
à l'entreprise en entreprise en a une
structure sur laquelle va venir
s'appuyer la stratégie et dans la danse
on a la technique sur laquelle va venir
s'appuyer le style je vais préciser un
petit peu plus
en parlant de la fonction organisation
dans l'entreprise la fonction
organisation elle va consister à
ordonnance et ordonner les ressources
les ressources et kouassi les machines
c'est les hommes on va mettre à
disposition des machines les positionner
au bon endroit dans le bon ordre les
hommes on va les positionner sur les
bonnes machines dans le bon ordre au bon
endroit
la fonction organisation consiste
également à répartir les tâches
répartir les tâches c'est répartir la
charge de travail au niveau de chacun
des postes des machines ou des hommes et
enfin c'est définir les responsabilités
des circuits d'information
là chacun sait ce qu'il a à faire ce
qu'il doit fournir quoi il doit fournir
est acquis dans la dent alors je vais
vous donner un exemple avant de passer à
l'analogie de la danse je vous donne
l'exemple d'une chaîne de montage dans
l'industrie automobile pour répondre à
la demande l'entreprise
doit sortir de la chaîne un véhicule
toutes les 20 minutes en sachant que
certaines des opérations sur la chaîne
dure plus d'une heure la fonction
organisation va permettre de définir le
nombre de postes à positionner tout au
long de la chaîne de montage va
également permettre d'identifier les
opérations qu'on devra attribuer à
chacun de ces postes
le nombre d'opérations et surtout
l'ordre de pour les effectuer
on va pas monter des essuie-glaces si le
pare-brise n'est pas posée par exemple
pour vous faire l'exemple vous donner
l'exemple au travers de la danse j'ai
reprendre exactement les mêmes éléments
de langage c'est à dire ordonné les
ressources les ressources pour le
danseur c'est quoi ces ses bras ses
pieds ses jambes sa tête il faut que
pour réaliser les packs le danseur à
devoir réaliser il faut respecter un
ordre répartir la charge répartir les
responsabilités
eh bien il faut selon le mouvement qui
va être demandé il va falloir apporter
plus de charges sur une jambe
on veut rester en équilibre on a un
appui qui est fort sur la jambe
on veut tourner on va se donner plus de
force plus d'impulsion
voilà on va répartir la charge selon le
besoin du mouvement on a comme
l'entreprise doit se développer et
devenir leader de son marché
le danseur aussi souhaite se développer
et lui son rêve c'est d'intégrer la plus
prestigieuse des compagnies de danse
donc pour ça il va travailler sa
technique il va vraiment renforcé son
son
voilà sa base ça solidifie il va
vraiment être solide avoir les bases
solides dans les jambes dans les bras
dans toutes ces ressources et il va
devoir travailler le style pour pouvoir
accéder à cette compagnie il va accéder
il passe le casting il est accepté il va
devoir maîtriser vraiment ce style pour
pouvoir préparer la tournée de la
compagnie la tournée c'est quoi ces 20 c
50 c'est sensé 200 représentations et là
on est vraiment dans la performance
pour illustrer je reviens sur
l'illustration de ordonné les ressources
répartir la charge pour illustrer par
rapport à un exemple je vais prendre
l'exemple d'un tour un tour dans la
danse c'est un mouvement très utilisée
il ya différentes formes de pour faire
des tours a honte ans moi je vais vous
donner l'exemple du tour retirer au
genou donc j'ai mis mes petits chaussons
et en fait la répartition de la charge
ça va être et l'ordre en parler d'ordre
aussi et d'impulsion pour faire un tour
il faut d'abord chercher à avoir
l'équilibré donc on va chercher la force
dans le sol on va chercher l'équilibré
et ensuite on va tourner et c'est
vraiment ça dans la danse qu'on
recherche c'est cet enchaînement ou en
tourne et on à son équilibre
voilà donc ça pour vous expliquer un
petit peu cet aspect de performance donc
on voit que l'entreprise comme le
danseur les deux tous les deux ont
besoin d'une structure d'une technique
pour se développer et pour atteindre un
niveau de performance le plus haut
possible
vous êtes aujourd'hui étudiant vous
allez bientôt
rentré dans le monde de l'entreprise
vous allez être confrontés à des
problématiques d'organisation de
performance
l'exemple que je vous ai donné au
travers de la danse vous pouvez tout à
fait elle le trouvait au travers d'un
art différent ou d'un sport peut-être ou
d'un art différent tout cas et moi
justement je vous invite par rapport à
ce que je viens de vous exposer à vous
approprier ces notions d'organisation de
performance sous un angle artistique et
pour moi ce sera le moyen
en tout cas si je vous invite à le faire
c'est que ce sera le moyen pour vous de
voir votre quotidien de rendre voc de
rendre votre quotidien professionnel
plus léger et de lui donner du sens et
puis si vous voulez une initiation à la
danse classique vous pouvez toujours
venir me voir tout à l'heure à la pause
déjeuner merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]